this is a sickness but I enjoy it the
douchebag tax
New York women are charging men up to
three thousand dollars for failed
relationships and bad dates
how are you going to charge me for a
film relationship how are you going to
succeed in charging me for a failed
relationship and bad day
how how are you going to charge me
let's find out Sarah's Fed Up the New
York City social worker who declined to
give her last name had countless dates
cancel on her at the last minute so when
a man she met on an app recently pulled
out of their date an hour beforehand she
agreed to reschedule on one caveat he
would vet more her a 50 deposit
thank you
okay then just agree that's from
merchandise
you're putting that deposit in so
therefore that means that you expect
something good if I put that deposit in
I expect something from you and [ __ ]
you better deliver
I mean be charitable be charitable if he
canceled and wasted her time she's
basically saying I want you to go the
extra mile to prove to me that you're
actually committed to going on this date
I don't think that makes her merchandise
I'm gonna pay for the day anyway so what
do you curl stop if I eventually go on a
date you're gonna I'm not gonna that
money I'm gonna spend anyways venmue you
some money get the [ __ ] out of here if
I'm going on a date with you I'm paying
for the date anyways okay if I cancel
because I got better options
better options
maybe some [ __ ] weather why you have to
be I can get I can get canceled on on a
daily [ __ ] basis it's that they got
better options maybe some [ __ ] came up
or some [ __ ] came up same thing I'm not
gonna ask I'm not gonna ask you to vamil
you some money that's [ __ ] up that's
just the name of the game you going you
don't it's not venmoing it's just whack
that shoot ass for venmo because your
time is vicious it's just [ __ ] weird
that [ __ ] like when one minute
they say that they want us to to pay for
the the dates and stuff like that they
really say like well I I put my time and
my money and this stop stop stop stop
stop
stop maybe some [ __ ] came up move on
venmo use some cash no we're not doing
this I don't mind this so long as when
the woman came and told her Bales and
there's another day set up she gotta do
the same if that's the case and I'm cool
with it
for me it's always just be like you're a
douchebag here's the monetary value of
my time you voiced it Martha Duke 38
told the post Duke said she's set to
around six venmore Crest ranging from
1500 to 3 000 depending on their
financial situation over the years to
different men she's dated she's listed
infidelity secret marriages hiding
having multiple sexual partners from her
so okay actually whoa
at first I thought these amounts were
egregious then I saw some of the
transgressions secret marriages yeah
infidelity no
no and that only cost two thousand
dollars hey [ __ ]
I [ __ ] [ __ ] Left Right Center not
even going front
yo I'm gonna be y'all I actually like
this [ __ ] yeah that's a good system
that's all I gotta do every time I get
some side [ __ ] I pay the hooker and
then I pay my wife don't even lie I'm
actually for this this is a sickness but
I enjoyed
this is perfect she has made any
agreement with me she has caught a deal
she has done all the negotiations and I
have agreed instantly because I have
realized that the deals he has set on
the table works to my favorite this one
is so stupid she has walked out of the
home today made a decision to [ __ ]
herself in the ass hole her anus is
ruptured by her own self she is perfect
we are going to say thank you eh we
appreciate you
that's a fire
green we're not getting divorced that's
way cheaper than a [ __ ] three grand
or a divorce 1500 to 3 Grand secret
marriages I can have a whole other way
[ __ ] her on the regular for three
grand again
hey I like this [ __ ] all right hey yo
one in the chat if you like where this
is going not a douchebag tags that's a
sight girl
that's a side girl look alimony no
that's just your admissions to the
player haters Club
that's just that's just that's you
you're not my girlfriend you my employee
I've been set up people Abba asked me to
go get the mail today because I received
this yeah it's the station and a
proclamation that ABBA is now a Lord and
owns land in Scotland there is no way
I'm calling Abba a lord yeah and there's
also
a confirmation letter the recipient it
is our utmost an absolute pleasure to
deliver unto you the physical
manifestation of your title and
certificate bearing witness to the
purchase of your plot what in Scotland I
did my little research and I found out
that it was a company called established
titles and that's what they do they they
are helping the global reforestation
whenever you buy land every plot of one
square foot that you buy they will plant
a tree and what's more they work with
global Charities like one tree planted
and trees for the future to support
Global reforestation efforts in Scotland
whenever you own land they call you Lord
and Lady you can actually use that in
your credit cards your bank statements
all of that your letters people will
call you Lord I refuse to call you Lord
Abba
yeah but you could do that establish
titles is actually running a massive
Black Friday sale 200 first people that
click on the link below that go to
established
titles.compreach use promo code album
preach we'll have 10 off not only that
I'm about to order mine yeah Imma Be
Lord too Lord preach
I like that
Lord Eric preached the third oh there's
a ring to it [ __ ] are going to
talk so much [ __ ] about the fact that we
have the same shirt
got this design
yeah where'd you get it
would I get it what the [ __ ] you mean
would I get it yeah this one where'd you
get it this is merch or Merch
this is the armors that I gave to you
that's how much you do not take care of
the merch yo
that's how much you do not take care of
the merch
where'd you get this
this our marriage
oh [ __ ] oh where'd you get yours
hey I'm not gonna lie
I didn't know this is our merch I'm not
gonna lie because this is really nice
I'm like dude we did this like yeah I
love my self-esteem is I'm like yeah
no we did not do that my bad guys uh
yeah uh you know get the merch I guess
it's so good days
it's actually nice where did you get
sorry guys hey hey you know I'll speak
to the guy who handles our merch my bad
my bodies you know
guys I feel bad so just [ __ ] bye Birds
that's good you can all move I'm just
done with my time and energy being
wasted I'm almost every scenario when
someone books a time on their day to
dedicate to you they have no show policy
or security deposit the man agreed to
the term sent her the money they met up
for a drink Monday night in Hell's
Kitchen and he was fully engaged the
entire time paying for their cocktails
and offering to buy them food live your
life if it works for you it works for
you I think it's stupid yeah if I ever
give you another shot those are text
messages imma need a security deposit or
something this is like I definitely owe
you a round or two now again sorry for
that no security security deposit needed
I don't like wasting time hey what's
your venmo
thank you you'll get it back if you do
everything right
you you know you know that's a setup for
[ __ ] just he's gonna do
everything right Revenue 50 bucks and
then just sleep with you and then leave
you know what I do after I sleep with
her and I leave and then go sir
Adventure another fifteen dollars that's
crazy yeah yeah not 50 15 yeah at tip
yeah she said I was gonna give you the
full amount but that service wasn't good
enough it's crazy might as well just
just my at this point might as well just
go through only fans and set up your
dates
you go like if you want to go on a date
with me subscribe to my only fans what's
on there nothing New York is a
narcissist capital
they're not going to understand what you
did really hurt my feelings because they
don't grasp feelings they grasp money
Duke says if animal Chris have been
cathartic and she submitted them to Men
Who offended her in various ways one man
had promised to help her with rent but
required a not so subtle reminder
another abandoned her on a weekend
getaway in Atlantic City because she
expected more of her a third dude goes
to her and resurfaced a month later to
another married to another woman when I
ran into him again years later he's like
but my divorce finalizes tomorrow want
to hang out
about half the time the shooters have
paid up Duke has been surprised at the
success of the crest but hypothesized
that men they'd rather pay to deal with
the emotional consequences uh yeah
sure I mean if I'm cheating on you I use
that two thousand dollars to get out of
it
Shane wrong we are going to do it I'm
not even gonna lie man I like this
I like this if it gets to me shut up man
there's times I've stopped seeing
somebody and they just pester me like
bro
and I would have paid a maybe not a
green a hundred dollars just be like can
you leave me alone
um listen I remember one time I left a
pair of pants at somebody's place okay I
really want the penis package again and
it was like dragging and dragging and
then after a while there was like some
weird argument she was like oh this and
I was like yo you being weird why are
you being disrespectful all of a sudden
and then when we stopped seeing each
other I was like can I please get the
pants back how'd you leave pants at
people's place okay with multiple sets
of clothes I get it yeah yeah because if
you stay over the night you bring an
extra set of clothes yeah so
so I'm like okay she's like no and I was
like you know what
yo keep it I'm not even gonna argue with
you even though what you're doing is
petty as [ __ ] keep the pants I just
don't want to deal with you you know
what I'm trying to say
if I could pay some money to get I would
because there's some people who Hound
you who pester you and it's just like
ref
why are you doing this
oh because your feelings are hurt oh
because you're you're feeling entitled
to something that you knew okay so yeah
um call it a douchebag tax call it
whatever the [ __ ] you want but if there
was money that you could pay to get rid
of somebody
I'm paying I mean technically there's
some money you can pay to you know get
rid of people but that's illegal that
that's really yeah we're not going to
jail we're not we're not we're not doing
that
that's not what I didn't say nothing
you said Hitman what don't put words in
my mouth